After years of experience with Manuka honey for skincare,
this is how I give myself, like,
new skin. After I've been traveling or,
you know, when you just had, like,
a long weekend, you wanna, like,
literally peel off your layer of skin and place it with a new one.
I'll first exfoliate. And I have the most dry,
sensitive skin that if I exfoliate,
I need something hydrating,
healing,
and barrier repairing on my skin that isn't gonna clog my pores.
And nothing's ever done that for me more than just manuka honey,
antifungal, antibacterial,
anti inflammatory, any inflammation,
irritation is just going to calm down.
And that's so important because irritation leads to inflammation,
that leads to breakout,
which is why I used to breakout after exfoliating.
Not anymore. I let that sit for pretty much as long as I can tolerate
because it starts dripping.
I run some warm water, clean towels,
soak this or a cloth in warm water,
wipe it off right after the sink,
I have some manuka honey, some water on my face,
gonna rub them in together.
If this on as a way longer face mask for, like,
a few hours. If you're going outside doing work or sweating,
I don't recommend. I'm literally gonna be in a cool room working.
Yeah, it'll feel like brand new,
fresh skin. As always. Let me know if you try.